معقول اسم الدوله مكتوب على هذا الجواز هو
انسان معقول نحن لانه سوريين بس مكتوب
علينا نهرب من الموت للموت للموت دائما ما
في مهرب نا ما في مجال ان نحن ننقذ انفسنا
من الموت دائما نحن محطوطين بخانه الموت
نحن عم ندور على الحياه نننا ارب شهور
بالحرب عايشين القصف للموت للدمار من
مدينه لمدينه بدور على
نشدنا كل الامم نشدنا كل المنظمات
الحقوقيه والانسانيه حكينا مع السفاره
حكينا مع الخارجيه نشدنا كل الدنيا لحتى
زونا نحن كسوريين ويخرجو عن طريق معبر رفح
ويحلو الى المطار لحتى نرجع على بلدنا وهي
مناشده كمان ثانيه لحتى كل الناس تسمع
صوتنا كسوريين انا ما بدي اموت انا ما بدي
جستي توقع على الارض وياكلوها القطط تحت
ركام هذا القصف اللي انت سمعتوه هلا هو
المحن محيط فينا من كل مكان وهذا الدمار
اللي انتم شايفينه هلا هو المكان اللي ننا
عايشين فيه هلا هذا قطع غزه انا هلا موجود
في مدينه غزه انا انس خطر بناشد انكم
ترجلوا العائلات السوريه وجال السوري من
قطع غزه بناشد الخارجيه المصريه الرئيس
عبح السيسي السفاره السوريه كل الامم
الصليب الاحمر الهلال الاحمر الاماراتي
هلال الاحمر الفلسطيني هلال الاحمر المصري
كل حدا ممكن يساعدنا لحتى نهرب من هذا
الموت بتمناك انكم انتم تساعدونا
ه